- [Ulli] So in the talk today,
what we're going to do is
look at how AI can help us
become more effective at
this troubleshooting, right?
How we can restore service
to our customers quicker,
how we can find the
root cause of a problem,
and then mitigate the
problem easier and faster.
Now, this is a level 300 code
talk you're attending today,
so which means we're gonna show you a lot
of hands-on things using
Amazon OpenSearch Service,
we're going to show you code,
but we're not necessarily
going into the level 400
of explaining every single line
of what we're doing.
It's more meant to be
an inspirational session
of what you can do in this area,
and how you can achieve
it using OpenSearch.
We have prepared a thorough guide for you
that will link to, in the
end, it's a GitHub Gist,
which will contain all of the references,
all of the code snippets,
and all of the material that you will need
to dive deeper on this
yourself afterwards.
So there's no need for
you to take photographs
or note stuff down, and
research on the fly and so on.
We'll all reference that afterwards, okay?
So my name is Ulli.
I'm a solutions architect
based in Berlin, Germany,
and my primary job is to work
with software companies
running SaaS on AWS,
but I'm also part of the
OpenSearch community here at AWS.
And today I'm very happy to
be accompanied by Rueben.
- [Rueben] Hi, everyone.
Rueben Jimenez, also a
senior solutions architect,
and dedicated to the
community of CloudOps.
More of the observability,
more of the optimization perspective,
and very similar to Ulli,
dealing with SaaS customers
and SaaS customers at scale.
- [Ulli] So before we go
into the hands-on part,
let me give you a brief
tour of the demo application
that we've developed for this talk.
So when we talk about observability
and we do a hands-on demo for that,
we need some application
that generates our observability data.
And what we've done here, for
you to have as a background,
is we've basically taken the
OpenTelemetry demo application
and modified that.
So the OpenTelemetry demo application,
if you don't know it, it's
an open-source project.
You can go and check it out on GitHub,
and it's basically a web shop
where you can buy telescopes,
binoculars, and such things.
And this web shop is backed by a series
of different microservices
that are all performing different tasks,
such as shipping, such
as billing, checkout,
and so on and so forth,
accounting and different microservices.
You'll see later on.
Now, the main modification
we did to that application
is to make it into a
multi-tenant SaaS application.
So what we're pretending here
is that we're a SaaS provider
that offers these web shops
to different web shop providers
in a multi-tenant fashion.
And what we did for that is,
we duplicated this demo application
across our different tenants.
And when you see these animal names,
this is our tenant identifiers, right?
So we have 10 of those.
And then we also extracted
some shared services
from these tenants, which is a pattern
that we often see in
multi-tenant applications, right?
So some things are run
locally for each tenant,
but then we also have shared services
that are running things
that all of our tenants have access to.
Now this demo application
is deployed into Kubernetes
and Amazon EKS.
And there is a another
component to be aware of,
which is these OpenTelemetry
collector component,
and the application,
so the different tenant applications
and also the shared services export
their observability data.
So logs, metrics, and traces
into this OpenTelemetry collector,
and this OpenTelemetry collector
then forwards this data
into Amazon OpenSearch Service.
And if you're not super familiar
with OpenSearch and
Amazon OpenSearch Service,
the kind of the main database or the thing
that is storing the data in
OpenSearch is called an index.
And then in OpenSearch Service,
we also have this component
called OpenSearch Ingestion,
which is kind of an ETL tool
aimed at OpenSearch, right?
So OpenSearch Ingestion takes the data
from OpenTelemetry
collector, transforms it,
and puts it into OpenSearch.
And then last but not least,
we have OpenSearch Dashboards,
which is an exploration
and visualization component
in the OpenSearch ecosystem
that we're going to use
to look at our data.
Now what you see here is a
very classic architecture
for observability, right?
So many AWS customers
running their applications
in Amazon EKS and running
their observability
using OpenSearch have
such an architecture.
So this is nothing new.
What we want to talk about
today is the addition of AI
to this whole setup.
And we're going to cover
three different AI use cases,
again, with the goal of how helping us
to speed up this search for
the root cause of an issue.
The first thing that we'll talk about
is natural language query generation
in OpenSearch Dashboards,
which will help us query
our log data quicker,
so that we can get to the
root of the problem quicker.
Secondly, we'll talk
about semantic log search,
which will enable us to
find pieces of log data
that we don't know how they look.
So maybe you remember that if you look
for a specific log line,
you have to kind of know
how that log line looks.
You have to know the specific words
that are mentioned in the log line
to actually be able to surface that.
But sometimes you just don't know really
what you're looking for.
And this is what the second
section will be about.
And last but not least,
we're going to tie
everything together using MCP
or model context protocol,
where we have an AI agent,
in our case, Kiro CLI,
to do a semantic search on our log data
and do natural language interaction for us
to not only troubleshoot
or find the root cause,
but also mitigate the
issue that is underlying.
So let me switch over to
our demo environment here.
And I brought up the same architecture
that I just showed you here on the left,
so this should be familiar.
This is our hotel demo application running
in a multi-tenant fashion.
And I just want to quickly show you
how this looks on a technical level.
So, if you don't know
Kubernetes very much,
kubectl is the standard tooling
to interact with Kubernetes
and Amazon EKS.
So what we can do here is,
we can say kubectl get namespaces,
and then we'll see exactly
what you see here on the right,
on the left, sorry.
We have our different animals,
which are our tenants.
We have this shared namespace down here,
and we also have our
OpenTelemetry collector namespace
up here.
So this is all currently deployed
in Amazon EKS and running.
And we can also have a deeper
look into these namespaces.
So we can say kubectl get pods,
and then take one of our tenants.
Let's take the falcon tenant,
and just have a look at
what's running in there.
And you can see there are
these different microservices
that are powering this web
shop that I talked about.
So you see here things like the cart
and the product catalog,
and so on and so forth.
Same thing with our shared services.
We can have a look at those as well.
And you see here the shared services
that all of our tenants
are centrally accessing.
Now you see here that, I
mean, here we see an error,
but this has already
been there for 44 days,
so it's nothing going on right now.
Everything else seems to
be running smoothly, right?
No, no big issues to see so far,
but unfortunately not everything is good.
In fact, just before our session,
we got a call from our
CEO and he's really upset
because our customers are really upset,
because actually the web
shops are not working,
like any of our customers
web shops are not working
at the moment.
And he said that people are able
to shop on the web shops,
like they're able to put things
into their carts and so on,
but they're not actually
able to purchase anything,
which, of course, is bad
for any web shop, right?
So we should go and fix that ASAP.
So as a first step in
troubleshooting this,
I'll do what probably an
ops person would do as well
and try to reproduce or,
yeah, try to reproduce the
problem on my own system, right?
And the way I do this is
using kubectl port-forward.
So this is basically a tool
to bring an application
that is running in
Kubernetes to my local host
to be able to access it in a browser.
So I'll do that again
using the falcon tenant,
and now I can access this demo application
from the falcon tenant at my
port 8080 of my local host.
So let's go ahead and do that.
Local host: 8080.
And this is the web shop
I was talking about.
So this is kind of the
classic OTel demo application.
And down here you have different
products at your disposal
that you can purchase.
Let's take this telescope
here, this looks good.
And then let's scroll down
here to place the order.
Nothing happens, right?
I click this,
nothing actually happens,
let's open the dev console of the browser
to see what's going on in
terms of network activity here.
And we see that there's a call to checkout
and this is still pending, so
this is taking a long time.
So let's see if that comes back.
It's actually timed out
now with a 504, right?
So there seems to be something wrong.
504, if you remember,
it's a gateway timeout HTTP error, right?
So something is timing out somewhere,
but in a distributed system like this,
it's quite hard to find
the root cause of this now.
So maybe, Rueben, we can have a look
at OpenSearch Dashboards to
figure out what the problem is.
- [Rueben] Awesome. Thank you, Ulli.
So as Ulli mentioned,
what we can do is we
can go into the console
or go into the OpenSearch
Service, open dashboards.
As you can see it's an
OpenSearch UI or dashboards
that specifically have
connectivity into our clusters
or a multi-tenant cluster.
What we have here is an application
or endpoint that we've configured.
And what we'll do is we're going ahead
and launch this dashboard.
Here we have our particular cluster.
We can go ahead and click on that.
- [Ulli] Can you zoom in a bit?
- Sure.
- I think it's a bit...
Yeah.
- [Rueben] How are we doing there? Good?
Maybe a little too much. (chuckles)
So what we have is, we have the logs
in terms of the multi-cluster
showing up here.
So what we have is, we have
kind of the look and feel for,
most of you that actually
have been working
with OpenSearch or OpenSearch Dashboards,
this should look very familiar to you.
Really kinda have the histogram here,
really kinda showing the
activity of those logs
that are actually put into
that particular index.
I'll shrink it just a little
bit so we can get down here.
And then from there, what
we're really kind of looking at
is how do we then take it
and really kinda look at it
from signal to noise, right?
So we have a lot of logs
that come through or that are there,
and how do we make it more palatable?
Or how do we really kind
of start to search for
what is that root cause, or
how can we start looking for
that needle in the haystack?
So if we were to just
kind of peruse it here,
which we all kind of know and
work with on a daily basis,
especially from an ops
perspective, kinda looking down
and it's really kind of a
lot of information, right?
Nothing that we can really index on,
or really anything that we can kind
of put our finger on,
right, in terms of that.
So what we wanna do here,
and you kind of ask yourself,
"Well, I could just go ahead
and I could do a query,
I could put it together,
and I could kinda figure it out."
That might take a lot of time, right?
And especially if you haven't
done it in a while, it's like,
"Oh, my goodness, where do I start?"
So what we wanna do is
then kind of ask ourselves,
could we use AI to actually
help us do that, right?
Could we use AI to give
us a little helping hand
in order to kind of figure that
out or what that looks like?
So what we're gonna do now is,
we're gonna go ahead and put in a prompt,
and then what we'll try to do is,
we'll try to narrow it down, right?
Kinda narrow the logs down,
kinda narrow overall what's
happening or what's going on.
So what I have here is,
I kinda have a cheat
sheet from here, right,
in terms of that.
So what I'll do is, I'll pop into here,
I'll copy this, and this
is really the prompt
that I'm putting in for AI.
So what I'll do is, I'll pop it into here,
and what I'm actually mentioning
or what I'm actually
bringing attention to is,
how can we narrow it, or get to the cause.
In the past, I've worked with this before,
and since I've been familiar
with the infrastructure
and things like that
and working with teams, I'm able to say,
this really kind of barks
like a dog and kinda acts like
in terms of an exceeded rate limit, right?
And so we've kind of had this in the past
and I've kind of seen it, right?
So I'm heading towards that direction
and see if I can get confirmation
or not overall for that, right?
So I'll go ahead and hit this prompt here.
And so what's nice about AI as well,
so not only did it actually narrow it down
a little bit for me,
right, in terms of the logs
and things like that that are happening,
what I'll do is, I'll open it up a bit.
Can kinda see a little
bit of the instrumentation
that went on here, right?
Looking for different things.
Ah, and it actually picked it up, right?
Rate limit exceeded.
And it looks like it's actually doing
kinda the ship-order, right?
Or the ship-order maybe being affected,
or maybe something going on with that
in terms of, could cause some problems
with the other tenants, right, overall,
or it could be a tenant
that's oversubscribed
and actually causing that
shared service to have issues.
What it also did for us, it
actually went ahead normally,
as I mentioned before, is
we could do a PPL, right?
And it actually did that for us.
So not only did it actually do an AI
or give us kind of some recommendations,
but it also gave us a PPL,
that if we weren't familiar
with really kind of how
to craft that or do that,
it gives it to us right
there and then, right?
So we have a reference
that we could actually do it and run it.
So it's very similar to the different PPLs
that you would run normally
in your operations.
So if we go to the AI Summary too,
which gives us a little bit of help here.
Ah, taking a bit to generate.
So again, it's saying, "Hey,
we did a sample of this,"
and it looks like it's the
shipping-rate-limiter, right,
or shared namespace.
That could be the smoking gun, right?
So it gives us a little bit more
and it says, "Hey, look,
it could actually affect
or affect these downstream
processes," right?
Or these other shared services
because of high traffic
and not be able to process it overall.
So we're now kind of formulating a picture
of what does that look like.
Now we're starting to
really kind of hone in
on what does that needle
in the haystack overall.
So, really, we could do this
and have some confirmation here,
but what we wanna do is really
kind of just look at this
and let's go through even kind
of some visualization, right?
I want to pretty kind
of kick that through.
But what I wanna do is,
I wanna kinda show you how this works.
So what we can do is,
we can actually do an NLP
also for a visualization.
And so, again, this is kind of, ah,
it's kinda not really nice
in terms of where it actually
shows it and things like that.
I think it might be an
upgrade or not that's needed.
But what we're gonna do is,
we're gonna put in a natural response here
and we're gonna see where that ends up
or what kind of visualization
that will confirm,
is our shared services having a problem
with other tenants, right?
So what I'll do is, I'll come back here,
and what I'm gonna do for
this visualization here is,
I'm gonna log the activity, right?
Give me the activity of
these particular tenants
and show me if there's a problem
or there could potentially be a problem.
And again, I like to think of it
as a picture's worth a thousand words,
and you can really kind of then see
what's happening or what's going on.
So as we can see here,
it actually generated a
particular visualization
that we can kinda see it.
So you can see the eagle
tenant is really, really busy,
really trying to process,
and you can see that the other services
are really competing, right?
So what we can really
kind of index on that
or really kind of just make
that leap a bit is a
noisy neighbor problem,
and a lot of us, in terms of EKS clusters,
and the operational piece, how
many times do we actually run
in the noisy neighbor problem,
right, in terms of that,
especially in the
multi-tenancy environment.
So now we're starting to say,
we really have this
noise that's out there,
in terms of logs, but now we're
able to really kind of make
that funnel a little more finite,
and then we have some answers
or we have some areas
that we can actually start
to dive deep in.
And Ulli mentioned these are
kind of just a couple ways
to go about, how do we
make semblance out of chaos
in terms of where we can start moving,
and how we can start troubleshooting.
And it gives us a little bit of foray
into the AI perspective.
So I'll hand it over
to Ulli at this point,
and then we'll go a little deeper,
in terms of the next kind of mechanism
or kind of tool in our toolbox
to do the semantic search,
and then really, really hone
in on what could be the issue
or what's going on
with the actual
multi-tenant clusters pass.
Ulli, I'll pass it over to you.
- [Ulli] So just to summarize this piece,
we've now figured out both the issue
that is going on, right?
There's a rate-limiting
problem in our shipping service
in our shared namespace,
and this is caused by a
noisy neighbor problem,
caused by our eagle tenant, right?
So it's apparently
they're doing a big sale
or something, overloading our system,
and affecting everyone else.
So, in this next section
on semantic search,
I wanna take a step back.
So you saw that Rueben
in the very beginning
put in this prompt like, is there a log
that is mentioning rate
limit exceeded, right?
Which basically tells you
that he kind of already knew
what he was looking for, right?
He said like he had
this problem in the past
and he knew a bit what to dig after.
But in lots of cases you
don't really know, right?
There's something weird
going on in your system
and you don't really know,
like there's this 504 gateway timeout
and maybe you've never
seen that before, right?
So you may be completely blank.
And in this case, semantic log
search could be of good use.
Now for semantic log search,
I will pull up this architecture here.
Give me a brief show of hands
who of you knows, in general,
what semantic search is?
Okay, so that's like a third of the room.
So let me briefly explain,
in general, semantic search.
So, semantic search is
kind of an evolution
of a classic lexical search, right?
So lexical search, what
we basically do there,
we compare words with each other.
We have a user query
and we compare this
user query word by word
with what we have in our database.
And in this case, it's log data,
but it could be other
types of data as well.
For semantic search,
we're evolving this a bit
and we're making search
available also by meaning,
which means that we're not
only looking at the words
that the user put in, but
we're looking at the meaning
of what the user put in and
comparing that to the meaning
of things that we have in our database.
And semantic search is powered heavily
by these vector-embedding models
and we have a couple of them
running on Amazon Bedrock.
And for this particular purpose,
we chose the most cost-effective
one that we have there,
which is Amazon Titan Text Embeddings V2.
And I'll show you a bit how the output
of those models looks later on.
But for log semantic log search,
we have to consider two,
let's say, specifics
about log data versus
other types of search.
And the first specific
is that we have log data
is typically very large in volume, right?
So it's not just a product catalog
where we have a couple of
thousands of entries maybe,
but even in our little demo application,
we're ingesting thousands of
log lines per minute already.
And of course, in production systems,
it will be orders of
magnitude more than that.
So we cannot just go and
run every single log line
against this embedding model
because it's an AI model
and this will like stack
up quite a bill, right,
if we do that for every single log line.
So what we have to do
instead is we need to work
with a subset of our logs
and just do embeddings for the subset,
and we're doing that using
a technique called sampling.
And I'll dive a bit into that.
Now, what's good on the
other hand, with log lines,
is that log lines are
typically semantically
not very different from each other, right?
So when you look at one
specific microservice
and the log lines that this
microservice is producing,
it's typically repeating itself
over and over again, right?
It's the same log lines,
maybe with different IDs,
maybe with different numbers,
like the time something took or something.
But this all doesn't change
anything semantically,
like it doesn't change the
meaning of the log line, right?
It's only like a different
identifier or so,
which doesn't change anything
in terms of semantics.
So we're good to do this sampling.
We shouldn't miss out
on too much information
because it's the same
things repeating themselves
all the time anyway, right?
So we're good to do this
sort of technique here.
So let me first show you
how we actually achieve this sampling.
And for that, let's dive
into OpenSearch Ingestion,
which I mentioned in the beginning,
which is this ETL tool
that we have available
in the OpenSearch context.
Now let's dive into the
logs ingestion pipeline,
which takes logs from our
OpenTelemetry collector,
transforms, and puts them into OpenSearch.
The log data that we've
been working with so far
was our raw log data.
And you see that we have
a little sub-pipeline here
that is basically just
putting every single log line
into OpenSearch.
And what Rueben has showed
you before was working
with this raw data.
But we have a different,
another sub-pipeline here,
which we call the sampled sub-pipeline.
And when we look at this
definition down here,
we see that we've introduced
this rate limiter in here,
and this rate limiter now
does the sampling for us.
So it takes only 10 events per second,
10 log lines per second per
service and will drop the rest,
which basically means
we have now a good kind
of little selection of log lines
from each and every single service
that we have in our system.
And then what we're doing
with those sampled logs
is we're ingesting them
into a new index and
OpenSearch called sampled logs.
So we now have two indexes,
we have the main one
that stores all of our logs,
and then we have the sample logs
that just contains a subset.
But with the subset of logs,
we're not able to do
semantic search yet, right?
We need to do some configuration
on the OpenSearch side
to be actually able to do
this kind of semantic search.
So let's do that together.
The way I'll do that is using
the OpenSearch Dev Tools,
and if you're not familiar
with OpenSearch so much,
it's basically a very
lightweight developer environment
where you have HTTP requests
on the left-hand side
and the result of those
requests on the right-hand side,
and we can just kind of fire
off HTTP requests, right,
and see what they come back with.
Now with setting up semantic search,
there are three steps involved
and we're gonna walk
through them one by one.
The first one is we need
to connect Amazon OpenSearch
Service to Amazon Bedrock,
because Amazon Bedrock hosts
the actual embedding model
that we need, as I said before,
and OpenSearch will be the database
and it will also do the communication
to Bedrock on our behalf.
Now the requests I'll fire off here
are a pretty boilerplate.
I'm not gonna dive too
much into details here.
What we first need to create in OpenSearch
is a connector to Amazon Bedrock,
and we will specify the model here
that we want to use in Bedrock.
And then we're gonna
take this connector ID
that OpenSearch generated
and put it into our register call here.
But we also need to create
this so-called model group,
and we'll also take that ID
and put it into our register call.
As I said, I'm going
through that a bit quicker.
It's all in the GitHub Gist if you want
to follow up a bit more in detail.
Now when registering the
model, we get this model ID,
which we'll be using for the
remainder of this section.
We need to deploy this model first
so it's known throughout
our OpenSearch domain,
and then we can actually go and predict,
which means we're testing this model now.
And the cool thing is,
we're now talking still
to the OpenSearch API, right?
So through the OpenSearch API,
this will call Amazon
Bedrock under the hood
and give us a response again
through the OpenSearch API.
So the two systems are now
connected with each other.
And this embedding model, if
you've never seen this before,
comes back with this long list
of floating point numbers.
And this is the output that
an embedding model produces.
And this, in a mathematical way,
encodes the meaning of what I put in.
So I put in here: "What
is the meaning of life?"
And this question is now
encoded into this long list
of floating point numbers,
which is our vector embedding.
Cool, so we have established
the connection now,
but our sampled logs
index is still not able
to do semantic search.
So we need to configure
the sampled logs index
to perform this embedding
automatically on our behalf
to be able to do this semantic search.
So let's go ahead and
configure this index.
When I look at the index so far,
and I'm just kind of
spitting out the definition
of this index here, we don't find anything
in terms of embedding in here, right?
It's not in there.
It's just containing all
of our plain log lines.
What I would do first is create
a so-called ingest pipeline,
which is a configuration object
that will enable OpenSearch
to automatically embed log lines
that are flowing into the index.
So I'm creating this embedding,
this ingest pipeline.
And what this does is just
processing all of the log lines
that are flowing in, taking the log body,
and producing a new field
called body embedding
that will store this floating point,
like array of floating point
numbers that we saw before,
which is the vector embedding.
And then we are going to
create an index template
for our sampled logs, which
contains this pipeline.
So basically, now saying,
please prepare this index
for automatically embedding
all of the log lines
that are flowing in.
And you see here that I also specified
this new body embedding field,
which is a vector field in OpenSearch.
And what I'll then do is,
I'll just delete the sample logs index.
And what's happening now under the hood
is that OpenSearch Ingestion will continue
to ingest data into this index,
and OpenSearch, since
the index does not exist,
it will recreate it automatically,
applying the configuration
that we've set up here.
So now the index will be recreated
using all this embedding pipeline
and the new embedding field.
So let's have a look at
this sample logs index now.
It's not yet found,
so apparently OpenSearch
Ingestion has not ingested
new log lines yet.
Let me repeat that a few times,
should usually take just a few seconds,
but sometimes it can take a bit more.
And there it is back up.
And when I now search for embedding,
we have this body embedding field here
that is now part of my index definition.
And when I go down here,
I also have this pipeline
as part of my index setting.
So what's now happening,
exactly what I wanted,
all of the new log lines
that are flowing in are
automatically embedded
by OpenSearch using Amazon Bedrock.
And this is the last piece
of setup I needed to do.
I can now perform semantic
search on this index.
Now we've been talking,
or I've been talking
so much about setting this
up that it's worth kind
of recapping what the
value of this is actually.
So, let's take a step back.
Remember we have this 504 gateway timeout.
I know that, when there's
a 504 gateway timeout,
it indicates that something
just takes very long
to process, right?
Kind of that's what I know, right?
I don't know anything of rate limiting.
I don't know any exceeded
or acute or anything.
I don't know how the
specific log line would look,
but I have an idea
that something is just
taking very long to process.
So let's do that.
Let's search, so I can put
in something very vague here.
I can ask for something like,
"Something is taking too long,"
and I can do a semantic search
for that to find log lines
that are semantically
relevant for this query.
So let's have a look
what it came back with,
and it's exactly again the
shared shipping service
that we saw before, right?
And it's found the log line:
"Rate limit exceeded. Request queued."
So you see that lexically,
those things are not related, right?
Something is taking too long.
It's not contained
anywhere in this log line.
But in meaning, in semantics,
they're very similar to each other.
So I've now gone from a kind
of a blank page problem.
I have no idea what to even look for.
I've gone to the log entry
that is going into the
right direction, right?
So now I can have a deeper
look at my shipping service
to figure out what exactly
that problem could be.
Okay, so having finished
our semantic search,
let's do the third part of the session
and do everything together.
Natural language processing
and semantic search,
bring it all together using
model context protocol or MCP.
- [Rueben] Cool. Thank you, Ulli.
So as Ulli had mentioned,
so it's really kind of the
latest and greatest, right?
So how can we have an agent
process these particular searches for us,
really kind of, with a prompt, right?
How can we use that same NLP
or that prompt to get
information back, right?
How can we use it as a tool
in order to interrogate
that particular OpenSearch Service, right?
And as we are moving into kind
of that agentic framework,
and I'm sure you're hearing
throughout the conference,
what is that agentic enterprise
or what does that agentic
framework look like, right?
So we have standalone agents,
we have autonomous agents,
and things like that, right?
So what we're doing is,
we're gonna use Kiro CLI as our client.
What we're gonna do is
we're going to talk to you,
or interact with, an MCP server
that we've actually
went ahead and built out
in terms of Python.
And then from there, it actually
has all of the scaffolding
that Ulli had talked about
in terms of being able
to use the model, use the embeddings,
and then go ahead and use that reasoning,
and then bring back a particular response.
And this was all kind of connective tissue
kinda leading up to this or
delivering this piece overall.
What I'm gonna do now is I'm gonna go
into the configuration file in terms
of the actual MCP server itself,
but again, in the Gist itself,
it has really kind of that scaffolding
of how you would set it up,
how you would configure it in Kiro CLI.
So, if you're kind of wanting
to dive a little bit
deeper in those settings
and that configuration, it's in the Gist.
So we'll share it up
there and you can go ahead
and look at it and try it
out or kick the tires on it.
I'm a huge fan of clear,
if nobody's noticed.
(Rueben laughs)
Ah.
So I'm gonna just go into the file itself
in terms of where the
actual downloads is or
where we have that MCP server.
It's kinda painful for you
guys to watch me type here.
(Rueben chuckles)
Goodness gracious.
Let's see.
Ah, it doesn't say it's there.
Sorry, guys, on that one.
We'll pop in here.
- [Ulli] Just add a main.py in the end.
- I'm sorry?
- With the cat, not a cd.
- [Rueben] Oh, that's right.
There we go. Perfect.
So what we have here is
just kind of the setup
in terms of where we're setting this up
or actually the main.py itself.
So what we have is, we
have our really kind
of our import boto3
client right from there.
We're actually referencing the fast MCP
for that particular component.
Then we're walking down
and kind of the OpenSearch connection.
There's documentation that's out there
that really kinda brings this to bear
or you can actually look at and reference.
So what we have here is, we have the host,
which is the actual search
or it's actually the OpenSearch endpoint
that we're gonna interrogate or hit.
We have the region that's there as well,
services, yes, of course, credentials.
We use the session and things like that,
which is in the AWS account.
So you can access it,
use that SigV4 access,
and go ahead and being able
to get that information
or query that information.
Then what we have is,
we use the OpenSearch client here
based on the Python piece overall
in terms of that client, right?
So it's actually calling it,
it's using the host and
using the variables above
in order to make that
connection or hit that endpoint.
Then what we have here is,
we're actually describing
the MCP server itself.
Fast MCP seems to be within Python.
The best way to go ahead
and do that query, right,
or do that interrogation of that endpoint.
And then from here, if
we really look at it,
it really just kind of boil it down,
is we can just put in a few lines of code
for that MCP server to actually
do a really dynamic fetch
of that particular model
or that embedding model
that Ulli actually set
up, right, initially.
So there really isn't a whole lot of work.
We already have the plumbing
that can actually make
that connectivity or
talk to that endpoint.
And what we have here is,
we actually have just a stanza here
in terms of MCP tooling that we can say,
"Hey look, we want you to
do that semantic search
and we want you to go ahead."
That body information coming
back and it's really displayed.
Before, we actually have that embedding
that will actually return
a response based on
that very finite query
on those 10 logs, right?
And then we also have the model ID.
So dynamically, we're actually
pulling in that model ID,
so that we can use it and leverage it
within the semantic search.
And again, as you referenced before,
we have the sampled logs here
that we could actually
leverage and utilize.
So what I'm gonna now do is,
I'm gonna go ahead and
kick off our client, right?
Here, the MCP client from there.
So, we'll clear that out.
So what this is doing
is it's actually going
into the mcp.json file or settings file,
and what it's doing is
it's setting it up, right?
So it's reading all of the MCP servers
that I have configured already.
And so one of them is the OS logs
or it's the main py, right?
That's actually coming through.
And as you can see, it
went ahead and welcomed
and it actually loaded it successfully.
You can actually go in
and type MCP itself,
and you can validate that
it actually did load,
or it did actually come
into your environment,
or within your MCP client through Kiro.
So what I'm gonna now do
is I'm gonna just type in
a particular input or an NLP input,
and see what I actually
get, right, from there.
So I'm gonna come down my
cheat sheet one more time here.
What I'm gonna do at that point is ask it.
Goodness gracious.
(Rueben speaks indistinctly)
And I'm going back to a
little bit to what I know
in terms of the exceeded rate limits.
Ulli said just sight unseen,
we could actually get it.
But again, I wanna see
what we're gonna get back
with a very targeted
NLP or prompt.
So again, on everything here,
we'll go ask, do we really trust it
or do we want it to do
what we say it wants to do?
So we'll push it through here again.
And here we go.
So it's actually showing us here,
it found a 500 rate limit logs
from the shared shipping service.
So, through the whole talk,
we've kind of been dancing around,
okay, how do we really
kind of close the funnel,
or actually start to hone in
on the particular root cause,
and then we see it again, right?
So it's more or less,
it's a problem with the shared shipping
and it's actually a noisy neighbor issue
and causing that component altogether.
So we kind of have
confirmation at this point.
So what we also want to do is,
how do we remediate this, right?
So we can just ask it directly:
"Remediate issue for me."
And so Kiro and really kind
of the whole AI component here
will go ahead and just
kinda give me suggestions
on what they can do in order
to remediate this, right?
Again, if I didn't really know
or understand what was actually going on
with that piece, it would
actually show me exactly
what could be going on in that.
So what it's saying really
at this point, let's see,
so it's actually scaling itself, right?
So it's actually go ahead
and it's actually scaling
this shipping, right?
So it's actually going through
and it's scaling it for me overall.
So, it actually went ahead and looked,
and says, "Hey, the
recommendation is scaling
that shipping shared service."
Then if we go ahead and scale it,
will it go ahead and
remediate the problem?
So it went ahead and gave us that,
or it kicked off for us, right?
And we went ahead and
said, "Okay, trust it,
go ahead and do it," right?
Very similar like, "Are
you sure you wanna delete?"
Kind of the same thing, right?
You wanna make sure that
you're adhering to it
and kinda responding to it.
So basically, it actually scaled,
so it actually gives you actions here.
"Scaled shipping deployment
from 1 to 5 replicas," right?
And it did a few other things there.
So this is kind of what it
fixed here, distributions,
and it gives you kind of
an overview of what it did
and what it didn't do at that point.
So what we're gonna do at this
point is we're gonna go back
into the application to see
if it actually did prove
to be successful or not, right?
So, what we'll do is, we'll go
back out on our command line,
and we'll see what actually
happened, if anything.
So we'll quit that piece,
forward again.
We'll just take a look at the
shared services real quick,
and see if it actually did.
It did actually scale it,
so we can say yes, that actually happened,
and Kiro did what we really
kind of recommended it could do
to solve that problem,
that we wanna do is come over here.
We wanna port forward.
So it really had kicked off before,
which is port forward here
on one of these front-ends,
and then we'll go and test the application
to see if that application is functioning
the way we wanted it to.
So we'll go back here to the OTel,
we'll go ahead and exit out of that,
and we'll continue shopping.
We'll come back in and
we will actually choose
this particular product, right?
We'll just kind of stay with
what we wanted to before.
Of course, our nephew wanted
this particular thing.
So let's see if we can actually
complete it or get it done.
So we'll add it to the
cart as we did before.
We'll walk it down here,
everything else is pretty much the same,
and we'll see if we can
actually place that order.
Boom, successful.
So now we've really kind
of have full circle, right?
So we actually went through
and we looked at it from NLP,
really kind of narrowed it.
We went from the semantic
search not really understanding
what could be the issue, but
then we actually honing in more
and more in terms of what the needle
in the haystack would
be, and then we used MCP.
It's kind of an external or an agent tool
to actually give us
that same confirmation,
to actually fix it and, and move forward.
So, with that, I'll go
ahead and hand it back over
to Ulli to take us home.
- [Ulli] So this already brings us
to the end of the session.
This is the GitHub Gist we promised
a few times during the session.
So do check this out.
It contains all of the code
snippets, documentation,
references and other
references, explanations,
and so on that we talked
about during this session.
Let's have a look at the time.
So I think we have time for one
or two spontaneous questions.
So if any one of you has a,
wants to have a question for the room
that we can answer, you can do that now,
if you wanna raise your hand.
Anyone here?
Okay. Yeah.
(attendee speaking indistinctly)
Uh-huh.
Okay, so just repeating
the question for everyone.
The question was for the connection
between OpenSearch and Bedrock,
whether we can have a
cross-region connection for that,
and yes, in fact, you can.
Yeah, you can do that.
In our case, we did it same region,
but you can have it cross-region as well.
Basically, how it works is
that OpenSearch is assuming
a role on your behalf,
and just calling the
Bedrock service endpoint
on your behalf.
Yeah.
- [Rueben] Any other
questions from the Ops side
of the house?
Go ahead.
- [Attendee] Just a question
on your demo, all those inputs
with dev tools (indistinct)
I'm showing you,
what part was that dev tool?
Is that something part of OpenSearch?
- [Ulli] Yes, it's a standard
part of OpenSearch dashboards.
So, OpenSearch is fully
HTTP API-based, right?
So, in contrast to other search
tools that are out there,
it's fully HTTP API.
And this is kind of the
main, kind of playground
that people use in OpenSearch, right,
to play with different play
with different endpoints.
Yeah. So this is nothing new.
This has been around for
pretty much ever. Yeah.
Cool. Okay, so with that,
let's close off the session.
Thanks a lot for spending
your valuable time with us.
We can take further questions
in the hallway, by the way.
We just need to move out in
a bit for the next speakers.
Happy to take any questions offline,
please do fill out the session survey.
I know everyone reminds you of that.
Please do for this session as well,
especially if you liked it.
We read every single piece of feedback
that you put in there.
So please do fill that out.
Have a great rest of re:Invent.
Enjoy the conference, and
hopefully see you all soon.
Thanks.
- Thank you, folks.
(attendees applauding)